the head of Toyota is saying that a
silent majority has doubts about
pursuing only electric vehicles for the
future of the United States I think that
that is absolutely true but part of the
reason for those doubts is the fear
uncertainty and doubt sowed by the
detractors of electric vehicles who say
the cars are too expensive well the
prices are coming down dramatically and
they will continue to come down the more
EVS are sold and the longer we allow the
technology to mature the cheaper they're
going to be well the range on electric
vehicles isn't enough the truth is based
on what ninety percent of people drive
daily any electric vehicle available in
the US would already have enough range
but range continues to increase you've
got the Lucid air and Tesla vehicles and
a number of other new ones that are
pushing three four up into the 500 Mile
ranges before you know it it's going to
continue to increase the reason people
doubt it is because they're being told
to doubt it